expresa 0.000 00 00 00 34 57
notación científica pero qué es eso de
la notación científica pues es
simplemente un número a que lo estamos
multiplicando por alguna potencia de 10
aunque esta es la potencia a la que
estamos elevando el número 10 y además
este número a lo escogimos de tal forma
que sea mayor o igual que 1
aquí está nuestro número a pero además
tiene que ser estrictamente menor que 10
ok puede ser 9.19 99 9999 1 pero no
puede ser 10 y bueno escogemos a este
número y ya esta potencia n de tal forma
que a por 10 a la n sea justo el número
que queremos escribir en notación
científica y para encontrar la notación
científica de este número lo que tenemos
que hacer es ir buscando de izquierda a
derecha cuál es el primer dígito
distinto de cero que hay aquí hay puros
ceros y llegamos aquí
este número es distinto de 0 y este
número es el único número que vamos a
poner a la izquierda del punto decimal
de nuestro nuevo número a ok vamos a
escribir por aquí 3.457 esto es nuestro
nuevo número
y queremos multiplicarlo por alguna
potencia de 10
tenemos que encontrar qué potencia
tenemos que escribir por aquí aunque
bueno entonces para pasar de aquí a este
número pues lo que tenemos que hacer es
recorrer el punto decimal muchos lugares
a la izquierda cierto aquí en todos
estos lugares van a aparecer estos ceros
de aquí ok y para hacer eso de mover el
punto decimal a la izquierda estamos
haciendo este número muchísimo más
pequeño aunque entonces en lugar de
multiplicar por una potencia positiva de
10 estamos dividiendo entre una potencia
positiva de 10 ok eso es justo lo que sí
tener un exponente negativo porque
cuando movemos el punto decimal un lugar
a la izquierda lo que estamos haciendo
es dividir a este número entre 10 a la 1
aunque si movemos el punto decimal dos
lugares a la izquierda estamos
dividiendo a este número entre 10 a la 2
aunque y eso es equivalente a
multiplicar por 10 elevado a la menos 2
aunque hay déjame hago un ejemplo para
que al ver si tenemos por aquí 1
y es elevado a la 1 pues eso es 1 por 10
que simplemente 10 sí tenemos 1 por 10
elevado a la cero esto es igual pues 10
elevado a la cero es 1 y uno por uno es
simplemente un 1 si después ponemos 1
por 10 elevado a la menos 1 entonces
tenemos 1 por 10 a la menos uno es igual
a 1 entre 10 entonces nos queda
simplemente un 1 entre 10 que a su vez
es igual a punto 1 cierto bueno entonces
1 por 10 al menos 2 es igual a 10 a la 2
es 100 y por lo tanto 10 a la menos 2 es
uno entre 100 y nada más lo estamos
multiplicando por 1 entonces nos queda
uno entre
y 1 entre 100 es igual a punto 01
ahora según yo aquí se ve muy claramente
qué es lo que está pasando cuando
tenemos enteros el punto decimal está al
lado de la última cifra ok y qué es lo
que pasa pues que cuando por ejemplo
elevamos el 10 al 0 el punto decimal al
lado de este 1 no lo estamos moviendo en
ningún lugar por otro lado cuando el
exponente es 1 entonces tomamos el punto
decimal y lo movemos un lugar a la
derecha sin embargo cuando el exponente
es negativo lo que hacemos es tomar el
punto decimal de al lado del 1 y moverlo
un lugar hacia la izquierda y si el
exponente es menos 2 entonces tenemos
que mover el punto decimal dos veces
hacia
la izquierda entonces regresemos con el
número del cual queremos encontrar su
notación científica ya sabemos qué
número aquí es el que necesitamos ahora
lo que queremos encontrar es cuál es el
exponente y bueno estos números son muy
parecidos podemos obtener este a partir
de este moviendo el punto es email a la
izquierda pero cuántas veces tenemos que
moverlo pues aquí tenemos que el punto
decimal estar por acá es este mismo
punto decimal y lo tenemos que mover uno
dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete ocho
nueve diez lugares hacia la izquierda
aunque aquí el exponente de diez
entonces va a ser menos
10 ok déjame lo escribo por aquí este
número en notación científica es 3.457 x
es elevado a la menos 10 ok y bueno
resumiendo lo todo que es lo que tenemos
que hacer tenemos aquí el número
buscamos el primer número distinto de
cero de izquierda a derecha que es este
número tres ponemos el punto decimal a
la derecha de ese número y lo volvemos a
escribir por acá
ok y haciendo eso aseguramos que este
número de aquí es un número que es mayor
o igual que 1 y estrictamente menor que
10 este número si cumple con eso no
bueno y una vez que ya tenemos este
número lo que hacemos es contar cuántos
lugares tuvimos que recorrer el punto
decimal bueno otra forma de hacer eso es
contar cuántos ceros hay a la izquierda
del 3 y antes del punto decimal y
agregarle uno por el lugar de este
número 3 y ese número es el exponente al
que tenemos que elevar al número 10